الطريق الى خرسون غيره امن من هنا بدات
القوات الروسيه بالمغادره لكن القصفها
للمدينه لا يتوقف
اثار عتاد الروسي ينبا بهول ما جرح الدمار
في كل مكان
تتدافع صور الموت والحياه في خرسول لكن
الجيش الاوكراني باتي يمسكوا بمقاليد
المدينه و يفاخر بان رايته لم تسقط
نتاشا تبدو سعيده هي وولدها بالانسحاب
الروسي من غير سون كانت ايام صعبه بالنسبه
لها
كما تشاهدون القصف مستمر لكننا لن نغادر
المدينه سنظل فيها حتى النهايه اغلب
المحال مغلقه وكثير من الشوارع فارغه
يحاول من تبقى من سكان استعاده حياتهم
للحصول على شرائح اتصال الاوكرانيه خلال
سيطره الروس على المدينه الزم السكان
باستخدام الشرائح الروسيه فرقت الحرب بين
كاترينا وعائلتها التي اثارت مغادره
المقاطعه في بدايه الحرب تبحث عن اي وسيله
للاطمئنان عليها الاتصالات في خيرسون ما
زالت الشحن
بوجود الروس
[تصفيق]
امواج
الاوكراني ورفي علمنا على المباني
يقول القائمون على المتجر انهم بدلوا
البضائع الروسيه التي الزم ببيعها سابقا
باخرى اوكرانيه دمرت الحرب بنا تحتيه
ومنشات حيويه لتحريم السكان من الكهرباء
والماء في وقت دقيق يشتد فيه الشتاء
بنظري كثير من سكان خيرسون فان عوده
الحياه الى طبيعتها لا زالت بعيده الملل
فالمدينه تحت القصف المستمر واعمال
الترميم تحتاج الكثير من الوقت تمر صمادي
الجزيره خير